I wouldn't do it's your boy Rich Homie
Quan Man and check me out on the bootleg
cab podcast man it's real day one [ __ ]
it's my dog man you got to check in this
you got to check this one up
bootleg cat show special guests in here
one of the goats yeah Rich Homie what's
up yeah man Quan what up man what's up
bro like I was saying good to see you
man yes listen man let me tell you
something when I say that uh I always
give you so much love when I talk about
just who really is like still I when I
hear music
I still hear your fingerprints over
everybody make sure that for sure that I
definitely had too I appreciate that
though bro yeah you're a legend I was
living in Tampa Florida
really when
2014 2015. it was different man it was
different you could go to DTLR you'd
have your clothing line in that
[ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] was
different man yes it was different bro I
just remember every [ __ ] mixtape
record going off at Club Sky and Ybor
City man it was just it was yeah you're
a legend man I appreciate that bro yes I
appreciate that man
um how's everything I know you got the
new album coming out next Friday
um now yeah we're just reloading it next
Friday
um Family Moolah now but you know I'm
posting music man I'm doing good though
man that's good I'm doing good mentally
you family you happy or for sure for
sure definitely happy man
um independent now so that's important
yeah I always felt like you know because
I for a while you were um I forget which
what was the major label you've been
putting stuff out with was it capital
Motown yeah I always felt like you were
kind of built for the independent [ __ ]
yeah me too man me too but at the same
time you know uh throughout my 10-year
run I'm definitely I saw every size for
Independence uh TIG label so yeah
because to think it's a game area for
people who don't know there was like a
point in time where you had kind of cool
off but it was also because you weren't
allowed to release music for sure for
sure that for sure that yeah so when I
couldn't release the music man you know
they just really put a dark cloud over
my head you know what I'm saying
Dark Cloud where I couldn't record I
didn't want to hear the radio you know
what I'm saying yeah was it like a point
in time where you felt like you might
have been like kind of dealing with some
depression or you just kind of were like
down in terms of just like you're just
on the music industry in general I would
just say depressed bro but coming from
that situation from the litigation where
I couldn't drop and that and
watching your pills just go up knowing
you can't go up you know I mean but I'm
still doing shows and
my heart just went into normal yeah
yeah I think uh you know when we think
back at just all the music you've been a
part of man
I was just listening to uh days before
rodeo and I was just like damn
Mamacita was so it's like a perfect song
that was supposed to be your record
originally it was my song yeah Mamacita
was my song original right yeah when I
said my song like
Metro man Metro was in the studio
together yeah and um I know when I left
the studio just me on it wow you know
and then it ended up with
all right let's talk about obviously ATL
took a big loss hip-hop took a big loss
uh one of your peers uh take off passed
away all right
that that [ __ ] me up bro you guys have
a very similar uh trajectory in terms of
just timelines of your guys's career
yeah that's what I said that's what I
was saying earlier like them that took
off at the same time like I remember
um
take all I remember the Migos that's all
being over there Gucci spot bro before
anybody got a deal Thug over there
Scooter over there the Migos on the
couch you know what I'm saying everybody
there so
just to see them grind to get to where
they uh what they are you know I mean it
was just like and to see where we
started from and watch every move like
I I saw them transition like they saw me
transition so it's like they're my real
brothers man so that it was a huge L
then me just knowing like
so that could have been me it made me
soldiers if it fold your brain man [ __ ]
with your brain bro I love Houston so
much like that's one of the Cities I
said I would move to if I ever leave
Atlanta you had no state taxes great
City yeah hey baby so that that that
[ __ ] me up yeah I can imagine man yeah
because I just think like you guys very
were like synonymous with each other in
terms of like who was kind of running
the club scene yeah 2014 yeah like 15 it
was like it was y'all
and it was them yeah like I remember oh
my
some type of way on Versace took off for
like the same time same time 2013. I
remember it like it was yesterday I
remember doing a birthday bash and stuff
together so it's like man we shot so
many memories together man you feel me
like and you don't even know you create
memories when you're living in a moments
like you don't even know they're gonna
be members if you feel me so I try to
cherish most of my relationships with
[ __ ] now bro because you know I never
know when I'm be gone what was uh I mean
I don't know how close you would take
off for but that's the story you you
have maybe you know whether it was
Birthday Bash or just a timer you guys
maybe had a convo or or had a memory
together that you know you always hold
dear
um like I said man it just mostly just
take man just him standing in the cut
man I always [ __ ] get high yeah SOLO
low-key last time I saw him was at qcp
uh P had a birthday party like a mid
gallon in Georgia in Atlanta yeah yeah
so man cuevo flicked up and stuff and he
was right there like the hair going in a
cut you say much but he had a blunt and
Dark Shades on you know what I'm saying
so
messages follow me different bro just
hit me different man then I know his
character he made me like you know me
quiet to himself
and the way it happened
yeah it's sad man it's a tragedy
yeah it's a tragedy because it's not
like you said like
it's not like he's the kind of guy who
yeah like he was was putting that energy
out there that's what I'm saying like he
wasn't even putting the energy in the
atmosphere you know what I'm saying so
it's different for somebody like that
like
sometimes people will pass and you'll be
like well look like obviously they're
wrapped up in a certain life or they're
putting they were kind of putting that
[ __ ] out there that's what you want you
know you live I just want you die by the
sword but that wasn't the case in that
situation man so like that's one thing
Atlanta been just devastated man
how is Atlanta I even I just heard
somebody talking that even like going to
Buckhead is hot right now yeah man boy
can't want to look on the city right now
I heard like you could you you like
they're doing the Smashing grabs and
Buckhead they're getting like because
you know Buckhead you could usually go
to Atlanta he's like I'm going to
Buckhead it's the night it's The Burbs
yeah Buckhead right I heard it's hot
over there right now
let's say Atlanta man you know yeah the
young boy it's hot everywhere though
with Buckhead is la is [ __ ] up too
you've been but uh yeah uh but Buckhead
is definitely hotter than usual you know
what I'm saying I know a lot like I just
said they're trying to get their own um
their own County uh on police they they
don't want to be part of Atlanta no more
they want their own City okay I want to
be their own City hey what up y'all
bootleg cab got to stop the interview to
tell you about our newest sponsor man
shout out to the homies at hardean Las
Vegas that's right the number one
dispensary in the whole state of Nevada
let alone in the whole [ __ ] country
so many choices of Premium cannabis
ladies and gentlemen it is like how can
I put this you walk into it you go to
Jardine in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why hardeen is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview are you
feeling the temperature in Atlanta
change now that we kind of know that
this D.A that's there is specifically
targeting rappers
in terms of just like are you noticing
it just from like somebody who's a part
of the industry and also somebody who's
a fan of what's going on in Atlanta are
you noticing the music change maybe the
subject matter changing people moving
out or people moving differently
um I would definitely say it's been a
big change since that D.A has got in uh
office you know what I'm saying but like
I say always man I feel like us as
rappers man we really gotta watch what
we put out there because like I'm and I
mean as in lyrics like you just said
like if I'm talking about game I mean
like Shoot Em Up Bang Bang music in my
songs what you think gonna be well what
type of crowd do I think gonna be in my
show or what type of crowd do I think
that I'm gonna you know get the
attention of so it's almost like and you
get attention from everywhere not just
like it's gonna come from everywhere so
you just got to be mindful of what we
say man and like you know
same plan she ain't playing she ain't
playing
I feel like you've been somebody who's
for the most part
had just Positive Vibes in your mouth oh
yeah like you know like you know like
I'm from the hood uh but I don't got a
rap about life
what's going on and I could just rap
about the Hood from my perspective of it
and just give stories and just put your
own game well I ain't trying to go back
though I don't mean like
but I could still make you feel pain
music without having to rap about that
you feel me I'm just trying to rap about
some everyday situations man stuff that
you can relate to everybody can relate
to shoot no gun yeah I I when I think of
Rich Homie Quan I think of like uh
I just think that it's so hard for you
to make bad music because you're so good
at this [ __ ] and I'm glad just to know
that you're independent now because I
feel like when you're in a position like
you where everyone might be looking at
you like man quantity had nothing for a
minute you kind of want to be in an
independent space because you could just
shoot as many shots as you want because
you know if something's gonna go in yeah
because you're rich homie Quan and you
do this [ __ ] bro
I think the break was necessary was
needed though man you know what I'm
saying because those at a time like
well I was a big headed bro and I can
admit that you know what I'm saying well
um I was on my high horse he fit me like
and I take accountability for that so
the break was really needy it wasn't
really about uh
me taking a break because the break
wasn't like I oh I'm finished here like
I was forced to take it and with me
taking a break
oh man I had to find you know they had
to face the man in the mirror man you
know and put something blind on myself
yeah
um what I loved about you was you were
tapping in with the West Coast yeah with
a record like walk through yeah shout
out to problem they set out a problem
man and then like uh with problems just
showed me new ways though because I
never thought like I could get on the
west coast type beat 92 bpms you know
what I'm saying that La record that just
ended up going crazy everywhere shout
out yeah shout out to Dupree the
producer who made priest a great guy
yeah man still work with him to this day
and it's just like man
um even with YG just like with mustard
like I remember first meeting them in
the studio Patchwork even we did both of
them same songs in the same Studio
differently yeah it's crazy because you
know what's Wild is like a record like
my hitter yeah
YG was having so many um he was having
problems breaking through outside of La
yeah and then he got the Rich Homie Quan
stimulus package but but like even like
to that story it is like yeah that story
like was crazy though like because even
like when I went to the studio I didn't
know who YG was like uh social media
wasn't like wasn't as popular as it is
now correct yeah so it wasn't like fly
called me and fly being t.i.g uh CEO
like man goes to the studio this West
Coast artists uh on YG I want you to
work yeah uh it was the sign of Def Jam
but GG was just you know watch notice I
was like [ __ ] I thought it was easy I'm
gonna go there and food so I go to the
studio man they're in the B room they
got the B room renting out and when I
first go in muscles on the computer but
I'm thinking muster is YG you know you
see the Apple computer nine times they
ain't playing stuff from his computer
right like watching what's up like this
High approach it
so muscle going through beats and when
he played the beat for the my hitter all
I could think of was I mean we ain't
going there and I'm a sample to this
something like this and Wayne was a big
inspiration to me and I was like man if
I could put my little twist on it it
would be hard
I went in there and did my part
um and I left two weeks later before I
called back Jesus went on the record
his voice was messed up or something so
he couldn't do his birthday so I just
did the verse I did the hood the verse
and I just left that's crazy yeah
classic classic Banger what is your
because I feel like you are one of the
when we think of like the t-pains the
acons the the guys who are just like 50
cents the guys who can come through with
a hook always what is your process when
it comes to coming up with a hook is it
a punching thing do you lay the melody
first then you feeling the lyrics like
how you come up with hooks
first and foremost the hook is really
created it starts with me
um beat selection Beach listening is
important and of course I'm punching
like but it's always off of field like
I've never went in the studio to make a
hit I just try to go on and make good
music I try to go in there and make a
song I would want to hear you know I
mean and I try to put no limits on my
creativity you know what I'm saying so
I'm willing to go in there and try
things I'm willing to mess up and I've
spent a lot of hours in that studio so
I'm confident in what I do I'm confident
in what I said I think confident play is
a big part in
yeah I think confidence and then
obviously you just gotta have that I
think your Melodies are so crazy like
you got to have a gift for coming over
those Melodies man oh I shout out to my
grandma put me on like that old school
music when I was little like it comes
from that Old Soul music like listen to
The Temptations uh who else received at
The Isley Brothers uh Kim right stuff
like that so it's not just all hip-hop
like r b too I like the oldies do you
ever look back at the rich gang era and
realize how
historical like the history y'all kind
of were like you were saying earlier
sometimes you live in memories you don't
know how important those memories are
because you're in the middle of it oh
yeah hey guys we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our good
folks over at bluechoo.com that's right
listen you gotta go to Bluetooth right
now sign up for uh Bluetooth with the
promo code bootleg you're gonna get your
first month for free Bluetooth the same
active ingredient as Viagra Ana Cialis
but in a chewable form that's right you
pop the blue shoe chew that thing wash
it down with your beverage of choice and
then get to work with that hard [ __ ]
[ __ ] of yours your dick is going to be
harder than trigonometry was in high
school ladies and gentlemen it's gonna
be [ __ ] Raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like are you
looking and he does the [ __ ]
this is gonna be your dick it's gonna be
like ryu's [ __ ] uppercut you know
what I'm saying God bless whoever's on
the receiving end of that consensually
of course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep in discreet packaging
no awkward doctor's visits all right
it's all online you don't have to worry
about going and sitting in a waiting
room and be like hey Doc uh my dick I
could use a little a pep in my step and
then it's awkward you gotta look at this
old [ __ ] talking about your dick he
might ask you to pull it out who [ __ ]
knows what's going on at Bluetooth none
of that's happening bootchu.com and they
also got the new brand new
a mint flavored chewable which has
vardinophil in it which is the same
active ingredient as Levitra and staxin
which is a little more potent a little
more potent if you need the extra on top
of the extra you know what I mean get
the mint chewable yeah your wife will
thank you your girlfriend no thank you
your boyfriend will thank you whatever
the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll thank you
as long as it's legal all right let's
get back to the interview go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg that's
it the rich gang [ __ ] just from a Fan's
perspective just looking back at like
wow that was long the I mean everybody
who was involved in Rich Gang back then
right that was that was just that was
that was a that was a what a time to be
a live moment man you know what I'm
saying and like I said earlier like
we're not knowing like we're really
creating history you know what I'm
saying we're not knowing that
we're gonna change the game and people
are going to start doing collaborative
projects now you know and this just come
from two solo artists collaborate
collaborating on music every day and it
was London on the track was handling a
lot of that production uh yeah London on
a trip you had done deal
um we had a lot of just a lot of Atlanta
uh a lot of Atlanta producers but London
was Hands-On
um that deal was on his own as well but
it's just us in the studio for three
months straight and like bro what are we
gonna do with the music when you guys
would decide you and Thug would decide
like
how would y'all decide who would take
the lead on like laying a hook down like
on like let's say lifestyle okay so
lifestyle so like for one like man man
thought we would be in the studio but we
would always be in separate rooms so
it's almost like uh we've always been we
would get us big enough Studio because
we're still
um solo artists and I'm like I don't
want to interject on your creativity as
well as mine so well so lifestyle was
brought upon
um
first day I met Birdman
um I did a show down in Miami came out
to the show and I had just busted my
face in the walkthrough video from
dehydration there but like he fell out
he's on drugs but I was just dehydrated
the other thing this 2014 I'm doing so
many shows I'm not getting no proper
rest and I didn't know you were getting
all the back end yeah I didn't know
about getting tired I didn't know I
didn't know I can fall out if I don't
get enough sleep you know what I'm
saying so I end up busting my face but
like two weeks after I brushed my face
I got a big offer in Miami you know I
ain't missing this money right put some
makeup on this [ __ ] so put makeup on it
but Birdman comes out to the show that
night Birdman come out to the show and
meet Birdman but Thug had already met
him man Thug had already been working in
Atlanta you know what I'm saying
what up nephew I think you should come
to the studio
they burned to see a bird you know what
I'm saying like
he signed with the who Wayne be with
yeah my mind thinking but that's they
probably go through the studio because
my dad came out to the club didn't I
right I probably go to the studio we go
to the studio you know what I'm saying
we're not smoking water water
it was like uh you want to get in the
studio you feel like rapping I was like
hell yeah play me some Beats
his Spaceball
a person you play lifestyle
but when I first heard it like
I was like I thought it was why I love
my dad like that way
you know I know there's stuff that boy
this [ __ ] thought was crazy crazy so
then it was like it's a person that
going I did the first part like 15
minutes laid it down lay it down I heard
him [ __ ] it was on the radio two weeks
later
radio two weeks later it's kind of like
a perfect mixture of like your Buzz was
crazy you had hit records already
Doug was bubbling yeah what's going on
you know what I'm saying but you guys
coming together it was like it was just
something crazy and then with the
Birdman approval yeah and it was you
know I mean like it was being young all
right I wouldn't like who was supposed
to go through what we went through even
like we was supposed to like that moment
was supposed to happen yeah you know I
mean it wasn't forced yeah you can hear
it in the music like you know I mean
after life so after lifestyle that's
when we decided like man y'all boys got
to be in the studio every day right then
we'll just come out he'd come out put
the project out you were kind of a part
of a a lot of the infancy stages of a
lot of the what we consider kind of
pillars in hip-hop production these days
right I'm talking about Metro booming
I'm talking about myself standing on the
track we go on and on
um
for you like who would you say was the
producer that is still relevant today
that you had the best chemistry with
what producer did I have the best
chemistry with
because like none of my songs like I
never used no like the same producers or
none of my big song but I would say like
who I had great chemistry with uh I'm
still working with that deal nice he was
on that rich game big heavy
um he just did Risk Takers for me
um
who was a
I don't know they told us I was just
been critical because like you just
cause they will never man hey OG in the
game you know what I mean traffic a lot
of people don't know he's actually from
the bay for real from San Francisco oh
he just dropped though that's that's the
that's a fat fun fact for today I did
not know that he just did a whole uh
album with uh three or four artists from
San Francisco for real yeah 415 yeah
that's hard people don't know that some
that's where some of his roots are
because you know everyone is he's
synonymous with Atlanta yeah as he
should be yeah but I I should have known
they're good at how he got yeah that
good Heaven and Hell yo you talked about
a day where you were at Gucci Mane's
house the Migos were there Thug was
there Scooter was there
Gucci Mane I always say probably is the
greatest a r in hip-hop history but but
like what I what he don't get enough
credit for he sees it and he be right 89
of the time and he sees it before it
happens
to sign the artist right I'm listening
he's not man RP the dog Dolph was over
there too listen man then goo walk was
pulling up on me at my mom wait Dolph
was at the house at the same time nah
this is difficult so Gucci trying to
sign me so now Thug already signed the
Gucci yeah he had the Migos too he had
the Migos
are y'all over there so you know trying
to real coin then so I'm stalling them
out I'm styling them out so I come at
them out of time he's like man where you
at I'm like bro I'm at my mama house but
I'm really just like you know I might go
I might not come pick you up
I would like uh
[ __ ] my side I go outside man but my
girl would tell her to come on too wow
he come pick me up man come pick me up
in the red Bentley he was like yeah only
two people got these in the USA he
popping off in the car with him first
time at me though so Dolph and Gucci
pick you up from your mom's house yeah
man dog would go but he was living in
Atlantic Station
and I just remember sending off on them
because I didn't know like at this time
I didn't I'm not dolphins not golfed off
yet right you know what I'm saying like
nobody I'm not I'm not even Rich Homie
Quan yet right you know what I'm saying
but dogs is like standing up sleep on
the elevator
we both spent the night in Goose living
room you and dog crashing on the couches
in Gucci's living room yeah but because
we couldn't go home he was like you know
it's a friendly kid now like you ain't
going home to just work around the kid
now but we haven't worked yet so I know
like yo bro what remind you and my girls
here too yeah man so let me get this
straight so Gucci pulls up to your house
in a red Bentley with young Dolph yeah
friendly kidnaps you and your lady yeah
you guys end up at his house you end up
crashing there in the living room with
dolphins yeah
because Gucci is courting to you to sign
with with Brick Squad no I wouldn't even
just yeah he wanted me to sign yeah he
wanted me to sign so you go over to his
house you guys end up recording yeah
he was upstairs man [ __ ] down you know
what I'm saying because like the logs
like they didn't have no door like
handling business like I don't like man
already cold man this is kind of weird
at this point yeah I mean the living
room he's up there [ __ ] y'all snoring
you know what I'm saying man I'm trying
to hit some [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying but you know I said it was a
moment bro like you know what I'm saying
Wild
what up y'all we gonna stop the
interview real quick tell you about our
good friends at my bookie that's right
man my bookie is where you want to get
this money and uh enjoy uh being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview what
made you not and what made you end up
choosing to TIG over over some of your
other people obviously Gucci was on the
table you know
I kind of just wanted to do something
different man like I was the first
artist signed the tsg
um
fly had this story in Atlanta called
flykus and for like kids was like
New York's Flight Club you know what I'm
saying okay but it was on the street uh
Peter Street and on Peter Street it was
a lot of Studio it's a studio in Peter
it was like uh it's like a little fun
place like people but his story you it
was the spot like even if you weren't
buying clothes right people just go
there to kick it drop CDs all you know
it was just kind of like Fairfax out
here maybe exactly it's acting like just
to have some motion just go you know
emotion and
oh no I just
gut feeling trusting him eventually I
just follow my good and I started to my
for a minute too and I'm good with
stalling because I try to fill out the
energies and Vibes and
I trusted it wasn't for a lot of money I
would uh Gucci offer me more money yeah
it hit me like I remember that well I
think I mean I think it did work out for
you because you obviously have a lot of
success but I bet it on myself though I
did I was willing to bet on myself and
take that chance though because like I I
got offered more money else places it's
just I knew what I had and
I trust it I trust the fly man you know
I trusted him not saying I wouldn't have
trusted Gucci but right I kind of want
the
uh make a new staple change the
narrative and be a part of some be a
part of a of Atlanta history in my own
little way hey and now they think when
you think of that drop think it's a game
that's like just
I know that because of you you know what
I mean
yeah for sure that but like I say I just
wanted to um I didn't really want a
co-sign I wanted to grind without a
cosign man because like I my great the
people I looked up to like Gucci's and
they didn't have one so I didn't want
one I wanted to be looked at like on the
same level less than one day I want to
get to the new music but I got to ask
you because I remember living in the
South and I would hear some of these
numbers that would get tossed around
about what kind of brown bags you was
picking yeah specifically in the Tampa
St Pete area uh listen man I ain't gonna
lie went crazy you were getting I don't
think people understand
there was a show you did in Tampa
and I had never seen the city more
excited for somebody outside of when
Boosie got out yeah listen bro it was
insane yeah like the badge was getting
in like because like
by the time some type of way came out
the world it went Global but I was
already in Florida from the differences
and can't judge her so I was in Florida
a whole year before some type of way
came out so I I was already up you know
what I'm saying you just had so many
Hood Classics at pop like what would you
do with something in the club even like
your feet like I know was a record that
was still to this day even like I still
like Florida and Carolina and like on my
biggest markets like I don't care what
is that in Florida I'm going to Florida
twice a month for sure for sure for sure
yeah it was wild because I just remember
like I would host these remotes at DTLR
and at this time there was Jewel House
boozy's clothing line there was Rich
Homie Quan [ __ ] and then the yrn [ __ ]
was for sale it was like an era that was
like so special when I think back and
I'm like damn like I'm glad I was living
there during that time yeah because I'm
not sure I would have appreciated it
being in L.A being on the west coast
which could but you right though because
it's different man even like with
Florida now how many floors are did you
see they merging them you know what I'm
saying like man like Plies like was a
big influence even like to be on such
similar shows with him like that's
somebody like yeah because plus had to
ran off on the plug twice yeah like his
arm like he keeps saying up you know
what I mean that even with him being um
actively on the social media like that
so it's like you know I mean that's
something that that's the lane I'm
lacking in because you know I'm very
private man like yeah I try to keep
myself not uh accessible like that bro
to you know to keep the confusion down
and you know keep me out the way and
keep me sane man that's that's important
um this new body of work uh any features
on it well not this new body no features
I like that yeah you know we had just
did the one I did the future with no cap
and you know I'm not really big on
features on my own songs you know like I
always
I mean really if you think your biggest
solo records I mean really the problem
feature was kind of like at the time
problem was like he had like what you
know what I'm saying yeah but that was
like a cool emergence of like what was
going on in L.A
it was like Atlanta music like I mean
Atlanta music your biggest records that
are Solo yeah are just you yeah and
that's what I'm saying so it's like it's
it's never like I needed anyone for the
hit
I was the hit maker so ain't nothing
like I don't know I'm not taking nothing
away from nobody because I've worked
with some incredible Talent
but man
I just love music so much bro even when
I wanted to quit I just couldn't man
yeah like I say I don't got no I didn't
have no plan B this is the plan B I put
all my chips in and even though it
didn't work out I gotta make it work I
gotta make it work
um when look hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg hit podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world that's
right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview Little Dicky bagged you up to
do the Little Dicky record yeah uh spend
that money yeah save them save that
money I have the plaque here somewhere
that's in the other room
um did you have any idea who Little
Dicky was because I know he paid you for
the future the full price full price
like he did he he paid you for the
future got you like did you have any
clue like about his wave or I I knew
nothing about it but I can tell you this
when they sent the song
I know he could rap immediately it's
different like
I was after because I didn't know but I
wanted to meet him in the way he died
the way he was so Hands-On with with his
business
I had never saw that you know what I
mean because right you know of course
like I have a great team but the way he
was like he's a perfectionist like a
perfectionist like facts pay me for the
full verse the way he cut my verse off I
thought was genius
but I was going I started going off too
so I was like because I did a whole 16.
so it's like yo man you paid for the
version he didn't use it but like it was
part of the creativity yeah he pulled
her to my house to shoot it like he
wouldn't take no it was in my growing my
house he didn't care he was out in the
hood right no security I think it's uh
Mandarin Temple and I think a dude no no
he's big like skinned with a ball head
not another guy's name got like a little
beard though
but yeah it ended up being a classic
video nah it did man thing went double
time Platinum man crazy yeah it's just
offs up dude hit you up like hey I need
a verse yeah for me just being hot
though and you gotta think like when I'm
doing frat parties and stuff I still
perform that song it's like depends on
where I'm at in the world depending on
where you're at you guys I like I
wouldn't do that song in Tampa but like
if I'm in L.A or if I'm at a college
fret party we're going up we're going up
like my car I wouldn't even do like
Mamacita in in Temple and I'm saying
that's for like there's no that type of
playlist is like it's crazy like it's
it's ratchet you know it's you know what
I'm saying so it's like when you got a
catalog like that depending on where
we're at in the world the you know the
playlist changes yeah
uh now that you're independent now that
you are I guess just free of any
obligations where you can just create
freely now
are you gonna put out music a lot more
frequently now
um of course I'm putting that music more
frequently uh we just dropped on October
4th which was my birthday I'm coming
back November 18th and this is the most
frequently I've ever been active in a
minute I was gonna say your first
mixtape series what was it I'll never
stop going still going in that's it but
the first one was I go in on every song
okay yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] it up for sure
but these are classic yes I go in on
every song still going in still going
there reloaded I promise I will never
stop going in
we get a fifth one they're still going
in they're still going in series Saga is
not over it's not over it's not over I'm
thinking about oh it might be my next
album I think but I don't think the next
one's gonna be a mixtape so this might
be a album yeah
with the stream and so it's definitely
not open man like I'm still cause I'm
still going in and
I'll never be able to live that life so
I could just hope I can create some new
memories man yo man well I know you got
to catch a flight so uh the new project
is out you got you you just dropped in
October like you said October for a
family of Moolah
um we got the
oh yeah the single Risk Takers which is
going crazy oh we got the dough cap
feature with bigger jeans which is going
crazy is there anybody like I was going
to say who you kind of see as somebody
who's got that same gift that you have
to just [ __ ] close your eyes and make
hits as part of the newer generation
uh I'm gonna get some slander with this
man but I think Kodak is tremendously
amazing I don't mean no matter what he
says like
I like I like his versatility like he
don't have just one set flow he's
unorthodox you can't you don't know how
he's gonna come on so I love that yeah I
think Kodak is on the like Mount
Rushmore of the last like five years of
rap maybe six years you know it's crazy
because he was like right after your
guys's era because that he was like 2015
2016. yeah like around time Uzi don't
pop and stuff yeah but he was different
it was it's the ratchetness but you can
hear the you can hear the dedication and
the real talent and you know that's what
I'm that's what I mean like
the the beat selection you know it's the
different flow it's the word play
because he's an alien yeah for sure he
got it as you are my friend Rich Homie
Quan one of the greatest I appreciate
that man one of the most influential
[ __ ] alive they know they know
come on man I appreciate you pulling up
bro thank you man thank you bro